Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 48. Ausgabe unseres Gesprächsformats, wo wir uns viel unterhalten über Wissenschaft, über Forschung, aber auch immer wieder über die Lehre und was sonst noch so bewegt werden kann in der Welt. Und man ahnt es schon, genau das Letztere soll heute ein wenig im Mittelpunkt stehen und mich hat der Weg nach Kiel geführt. Genau an die Universität Kiel. Und ich begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner für heute Christoph Corves, schönen guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag Herr Pritlove.
hier sind wir an der Universität Kiel. Um es kurz vorwegzunehmen, Sie sind hier Professor für Geographie und Medien einen dementsprechend benannten Institut. Aber bevor wir da vielleicht noch einmal genauer auch darauf eingehen, würde mich so ein bisschen Vorgeschichte interessieren. Denn ich habe erfahren, dass Sie ja eigentlich früher irgendwie auch mal was ganz anderes gemacht haben. Und teilweise glaube ich sogar als Journalist und Fotograf unterwegs waren, aber vor allem auch als Dokumentarfilmer. Stimmt das?
ja das stimmt. Vielleicht muss ich noch einen Tick weiter ausholen. Ich habe angefangen, ich habe von früher auch so den Drang gehabt, Dinge in der Welt, die ich als nicht gut oder nicht gerecht finde, verändern zu können. Und ich habe dann immer, als ich meinen Zivildienst gemacht hatte, habe ich gesucht nach einer Möglichkeit, wie ich das studieren kann, was diesem Ziel eigentlich, was sinnvoll verändern zu können, nahekommt. Und hatte also, als bei mir diese Frage anstand, buchstäblich fünf komplett unterschiedliche Studiengänge, die reichten von Politik an der FU Berlin über Lehmbauarchitektur an der Gesamthochschule Kassel zu Meeresbiologen an der Uni Kiel. Und ich hatte auch noch den ersten Studiengang, wo man erneuerbare Energien studieren konnte, in Stuttgart ausfindig gemacht. Hatte mich dann auch überall entschieden, weil ich mich nicht entscheiden konnte. Und bin dann gelandet an der Uni Kiel mit Biologie.
Und habe dann spätestens nach der zweiten Woche, als es dann an die Sezierübungen ging, die Tiere wurden dann leider immer größer, die dann seziert werden sollten, teilweise auch lebend, sehr schnell gemerkt, dass dieser Zugang eigentlich zu der Frage, wie kann man sinnvoll etwas verändern auf der Welt, die Fragen zwar in der Biologie interessant waren, aber die Herangehensweisen nicht meinen Vorstellungen entsprachen. Und spätestens als es dann um die Frösche und Ratten ging, habe ich dann lieber jemanden angeheuert, der das für mich gemacht hat. Die Kurse waren groß genug, dass das nicht auffiel. Und ich habe dann, ja das hört sich jetzt natürlich lustig an, aber ich habe dann lange über Jahre mit dieser Frage gerungen, liegt es an mir, liegt es am Studiengang, oder was ist eigentlich das Problem? Ich wollte ein bisschen mehr von der Welt sehen, ich habe das damals in Kiel angefangen. Das war damals mit der zentralen Vermittlung von Studienplätzen. Man kriegte den Studiengang, an dem Standort, der am nächsten beim Heimat Ort der Eltern war.
Was man eigentlich genau nicht wollte. Das war für mich Kiel. Und ich habe dann die nächste Möglichkeit genutzt, um ins Ausland zu kommen. Hatte dann viele Auslandsstipendien beantragt und es kam einfach so, dass ich die erste Möglichkeit hatte, dann nach Edinburgh zu gehen in Schottland. Das war 86. Und habe dann kennengelernt ein Modell, wo man sehr frei studieren konnte. Wo man sich eine Fragestellung selber suchen konnte und dann eine Betreuung kam, um sich damit zu beschäftigen und das vertieft zu tun. Und ich hatte damals die Frage für mich, die mich interessierte, war, warum es eigentlich zu Regenwaldvernichtung im Amazonasgebiet kommt. Also das war das Centre for Human Ecology, konnte mich damit beschäftigen. War dann auch mehrere Monate im Amazonas mit einem Kollegen. Habe einen Bericht geschrieben. War danach im Jahr wieder in Kiel. Habe hier eine große Ringvorlesung organisiert mit einer Kollegin der Geographie, der Biologie, der Agrarwissenschaft, zu dem Thema, wie kommt es eigentlich zu Regenwaldvernichtung, was löst das aus?
na gut das war sehr erfolgreich, aber irgendwann war das vorbei und dann drohte wieder dieser normale Studienalltag. Ich war immer noch in Biologie eingeschrieben und hatte eigentlich alles, was an Lehrveranstaltungen so gemacht werden musste, erledigt und mir standen eigentlich noch diese Diplomprüfungen bevor. Und ich hatte mich dann sicherheitshalber wieder auf Auslandsstipendien beworben. Verbrachte den Sommer in Falkenstein am Strand, immer mit einem großen Fahrradkorb voller Lehrbücher, um diese Prüfung vorzubereiten. Kam aber nie dazu. Und ich kriegte dann Gott sei Dank ein Schreiben vom DAAD vom akademischen Austauschdienst, wurde mir ein weiteres Stipendium für Edinburgh anboten. Und ich dachte, das ist ein Wink des Himmels sozusagen, ich brauche dieses Diplom in Kiel eigentlich gar nicht. Ich mache jetzt ein Masterstudiengang direkt in Edinburgh in geographische Informationssysteme und Satellitenkartierung.
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt war das dann?
Das war 89.
Da stand das ja alles noch sehr in den Babyschuhen?
Genau. Aber es kam so, das war damals ganz neue diese Thematik. Ich musste mich damals selber einarbeiten, weil es eigentlich keinen Experten gab da an der Uni, aber die hatten zumindest eine sehr gute Software, die es in Kiel nicht gab und das war klasse. Damit konnte ich das machen. Und habe dann da den Master gemacht. Und wie das dann so spielt im Leben, meine Partnerin kennen gelernt. Eine Spanierin und wir waren danach zusammen erst einmal ein Jahr in Südamerika, in Bolivien. Und sie hat er geforscht. Ich hatte die wunderbare Möglichkeit, Fotos zu machen und Videos zu machen. Weil das war immer eigentlich das was du als Hobby mein Leben so begleitet hat, visuell zu arbeiten.
So in den Neunzigern hat das ja auch noch nicht jeder getan. Da war das ja noch was besonderes.
Wir haben ein Jahr gelebt auf einer kleinen Insel, in einer Aymara-Community von Indianern auf der Sonneninsel im Titicacasee. Das war also zwischen anstrengend und sehr exotisch. Zwischenzeitlich kam dann meine Anschlussfinanzierung, weil ich wollte ja meiner Freundin auch nicht ewig auf der Tasche liegen, die zwar ein sehr gutes Stipendium der spanischen Regierung hatte, aber ich hatte mich dann wieder beworben bei EU Fördermöglichkeiten und hatte dann ein Projekt bekommen für Satellitenkartierung im Amazonasgebiet. Was ich dann aus dem Master fortgesetzt habe. Und da ging es um die Kartierung von Tropenwäldern, um Überschwemmungsebenen und vor allen Dingen von Waldvernichtung eine großflächige Kartierung. Und wir sind dann von Bolivien direkt drunter nach Manaus und waren dann drei Monate da. Ich habe das dann fortgesetzt, nachdem wir wieder in Edinburgh waren, also ich war 5-6 Jahre in Edinburgh bis Mitte der 90er, in Form der Doktorarbeit zum Thema Satellitenkartierung von Waldvernichtung.
Und für mich war also, es gab zwei prägende Ergebnisse, als ich die Doktorarbeit fertig hatte. Erstens war, als es ließ sich sehr gut veröffentlichen dieser Tatsachen in internationalen Zeitschriften. Aber eigentlich hat an den Ergebnissen nur die Loggingindustrie Interesse. Die Interesse hatten einen guten Karten, um zu gucken, wie kommen Sie leichten an Wälder dran, die sie auch noch abholzen können.
Oha.
und das war so, dass stellte für mich doch sehr infrage, ob Wissenschaft eigentlich ein guter Zugang ist, die Welt zu verbessern oder ob das möglicherweise doch zu indirekt ist. Und ich habe dann mit meiner Partnerin beschlossen, als wir die 5-6 Jahre in Edinburgh hinter uns hatten, wir sind dann nach Berlin gegangen und haben eine Firma gegründet für die Produktion von Dokumentarfilmen fürs Fernsehen. Weil wir dachten, Dokumentarfilme, Bildung, Information in Fernsehen ist eigentlich eher geeignet, da kann man sehr viele Leute erreichen. Das ist eigentlich eher geeignet, um auf der Welt etwas positiv zu verändern, als dass über wissenschaftliche Forschung und Zeitschriften zu machen. Und so bin ich damals bei den Dokumentarfilmen gelandet.
Dann gab es wie viele Produktionen, wie viele sind da aus dieser Ära hervor gekommen?
Das sind gar nicht so viele große Produktionen. Also werden längere Filme gemacht, so zwischen einer Dreiviertelstunde und anderthalb Stunden. Für Sender wie NDR oder Arte oder ORB, die ARD und das waren vier Filme. Das waren jeweils Filme, die sich über 3-4 Jahre erstreckt haben, weil wir über mehrere Jahre gedreht haben. Wo wir natürlich auch geguckt haben, was können wir besser machen also ein Fernsehsender? Wir können halt Sachen, wenn wir unsere Honorare günstig kalkulieren, können wir Sachen sehr gut machen, die lange Recherche und lange Drehs erfordern. Und wir hatten einen Film gemacht über die Frage, die biologische Vielfalt in der Landwirtschaft was das mit Klimawandel zu tun hat, das war damals der Zeit eher voraus. Ist aber ein Film geworden, der sehr oft gesendet worden ist in Deutschland, auch in den USA, im Hochschulsystem sehr weit verbreitet war. Dann haben wir eine Reihe Filme gemacht über die Frage, wie der Weltmarkt für Zucker funktioniert.
Wo wir an sehr vielen Orten gedreht haben. Wir haben gedreht hier, wie das dann sein muss, wenn das ein Film für den NDR ist, dann müssen Sie in Norddeutschland drehen. Wir hatten also einen Zuckerrübenanbau in Dithmarschen, bei dem wir immer wieder gedreht haben. Wir haben mit Nordzucker im weiteren norddeutschen Bereich gedreht. Wir waren aber auch in der Dominikanischen Republik, haben da gefilmt, wie auf Plantagen Leute eigentlich wie in der Sklavenzeit gehalten werden, Wanderarbeiter aus Haiti. Was ein komplizierter Dreh war. Wir waren in Mexiko, haben in den USA gedreht an der Warenterminbörse für Zucker. Also dass man sehen kann, das waren Filme, die halt versucht haben, eigentlich geografische Themen zu packen in einen Film, so dass auch komplexe Ideen verstanden werden können durch Leute, die eigentlich mit der Thematik sonst nichts zusammen haben. Und wir haben immer versucht das Filmmedium und Personifizierungen zu nutzen, um Leute in so ein Thema reinzuziehen.
Hat man denn das Gefühl dann, dass man mit diesen Filmen auch das erreicht, was es vielleicht so am Anfang versprach?
Das haben wir uns natürlich auch immer gefragt. Also führt das zu Veränderungen oder führt das nicht zu Veränderungen? Und ich würde so aus jetziger Perspektive sagen, dass Wissen und Information natürlich sehr langfristig vielleicht Verhalten verändert, aber sicher nicht im kurzfristigen. Das weiß man ja auch aus der ganzen Umweltbildung, dass etwas zu wissen führt nicht dazu, dass man sich anders verhält. Dann bräuchten wir nur angucken das Thema Klimaschutz. Ich wohne außerhalb von Kiel, 25 Kilometer außerhalb, eigentlich würde sich verbieten ein Auto zu benutzen. Aber so wie die Verkehrsverbindungen nun mal sind, benutze ich trotzdem täglich ein Auto. Und wenn ich das so übers Jahr zusammenrechne und das eingebe in den CO2-Rechner vom Umweltbundesamt, dann wird einem auch sofort klar, dass also unser energiesparendes Haus und unsere Ökoernährung, die auf Fleisch verzichtet, sofort überkompensiert wird durch das Auto, um zur Arbeit zu kommen.
Wo ich hier mich mit Nachhaltigkeitsthemen dann in der Lehre beschäftige.
Fehlt noch das Elektroauto sozusagen.
Ja oder andere Leute sagen dann, warum ziehst du nicht um nach Kiel? Aber das hat nun persönliche Gründe, dass wir das nicht machen.
Okay.
Aber was uns bei den Filmen klar wurde ist, dass eigentlich auch Wissen, was man über Medien verbreitet, nicht dazu notwendigerweise führt, dass sich auf der Welt Dinge positiv verändern, was mich dann nach Jahren auch dazu zurückgebracht hat, wieder an die Hochschule zu gehen. Weil ich denke, dass Bildung mittelfristig viel mehr verändert. Wenn wir jungen Leuten eigentlich Handlungsmöglichkeiten eröffnen, wenn wir dafür Räume schaffen an Hochschulen, dann passieren reale Veränderungen. Vielleicht im Kleinen, vielleicht werden die mit den Jahren auch größer, aber so da hat sich eigentlich dann durch die Möglichkeit, hier nach Kiel zu kommen, wieder so dieses Handlungsfeld erschlossen, eröffnet, und was ich jetzt mache, damit bin ich glücklich.
Okay. Wenn man … also es gibt jetzt so viele Sachen, wo ich jetzt noch quer nochmal nachfragen könnte, ich versuche mich zu beschränken. Aber diese Erfahrung, Amazonas, Abholzung, andere Eindrücke so aus aller Welt, so dieses Unmittelbare und nicht nur aus zweiter und dritter Hand Erfahrene und dann in gewisser Hinsicht findet glaube ich, wenn man sowas auch noch dokumentiert, dann steigt man ja noch viel tiefer ein, weil man sich ja quasi auch die Hintergründe noch erarbeitet. Da muss einem doch so ein bisschen der Kopf platzen auch oder? Also wenn man das alles so weiß und sieht und das dann in Verhältnis setzt zu dem, was dann tatsächlich geschieht mit amerikanischen Präsidenten, die das irgendwie wiedermal komplett in eine andere Richtung gießen wollen? Wie geht man damit um?
Ich denke, man bewegt sich ja immer in diesem Spagat. Einerseits so globale Veränderungen und Probleme halt einerseits wahrzunehmen und dann natürlich trotzdem, das gilt zumindest für mich, eigentlich nicht die Hoffnung aufzugeben und dass die Welt sich aber – ich will nicht sagen – retten lässt, aber zum besseren verändern lässt. Und dass man dann guckt, welche Handlungsmöglichkeiten gibt es? Also ich glaube ich bin realistischer geworden bei der Einschätzung, welche Handlungsmöglichkeiten habe ich und was kann ich in dem Umfeld, wo ich mich jetzt befinde, was kann ich dazu beitragen? Und ich denke, ich sehe vieles auf der Welt so in Form von Gleichgewichten. Habe ich vielleicht zu lange auch in meinem Biologiestudium mit Chemie zu tun gehabt. Aber ich denke immer sozusagen, es gibt halt Prozesse, die halt Dinge ins Ungleichgewicht bringen und einfach schlechte oder dramatische Folgen nach sich ziehen. Klimaschutz und alles mögliche fällt einem da ein.
Ungerechtigkeit auf der Welt. Verteilungsprobleme. Und deswegen gibt es halt die Notwendigkeit, sich auf der anderen Seite dafür einzusetzen, die Dinge wieder ins Lot zu bringen. Was nicht heißt, dass man das Paradies erreicht, dafür bin ich nicht christlich genug. Aber dass es halt notwendig ist, das trotzdem zu machen und zu gucken, was man in seinem Bereich halt machen kann.
Den Platz etwas sauberer hinterlassen, als man ihn vorgefunden hat sozusagen?
Ja ich denke eigentlich inzwischen, also ich habe mich auch lange mit Fragen so Entwicklungszusammenhalt beschäftigt, ich glaube, man kann so große Systeme nicht von heute auf morgen verändern. Aber trotzdem hat es natürlich eine Notwendigkeit, das trotzdem zu tun. Weil man ja sieht, es hilft bestimmten Personen, die Möglichkeiten dadurch erhalten, die sie vielleicht nicht gehabt hätten. Ich sehe das bei Studierenden, ich kann nicht alle Studierenden in Deutschland erreichen, das sind über 2,7 Millionen, aber ich kann eine erhebliche Anzahl von Studierenden hier an der Uni Kiel erreichen. Die hier Sachen machen können in unserem Zukunftsmacher-Programm. Die sie an einer anderen Hochschule nicht so einfach machen könnten. Und das sind vielleicht 100 im Jahr und denen eröffnen wir hier so einen Handlungsraum, wo die bestimmte Dinge lernen können und ich glaube das hat einen Wert an sich. Auch wenn ich vielleicht nicht das was ich gerne würde, ich kann nicht für 2,5 oder 2,7 Millionen Studierende bundesweit verändern wie sie lernen. Zumindest nicht mal eben so schnell. Aber wir können ein Programm anstoßen, was zunehmend mehr Studierenden das ermöglicht. Und da sind wir bei.
Ja damit kommen wir ein bisschen mehr hier zur Realität an der Universität Kiel. Also jetzt ich habe es ja schon angesprochen, Geografie, Medien, steht hier zumindest offiziell auf diesem Institut. Was für Aktivitäten geschehen hier? Was ist denn dann hier entstanden aus der neuen Chance?
Also wie Sie sagen, die Stelle ist ja ursprünglich definiert als Geografie und Medien. Und natürlich gibt es einerseits dann hier in den Studiengängen der Geografie, insbesondere im Bachelor, aber halt auch in unserem internationalen Master für Sustainability, Society and Reenvironment gibt es halt Angebote im Medienbereich, Dinge zu machen. Zum Beispiel im Bereich Kommunikation, zum Beispiel im Bereich wie ich produziere ich kleines Video, wie man das vielleicht braucht für eine Kampagne oder wie man das braucht als NGO. Oder halt auch durchaus Sachen, die so das Niveau haben, dass sie in so Regionalmagazinen im Fernsehen kommen könnten. Ja das ist so dieser Medienbereich. Einer der Anstöße, also ich wollte immer, dass eigentlich was ich mir selber gewünscht hätte im Studium, dass man lernen kann, wie man die Welt positiv verändert und eigentlich nicht nur Fakten und Grundlagen nennt. Sondern eigentlich zu lernen, wie man selber ein Problem lösen kann.
Das ist dieser Begriff Teaching for Empowerment, der da immer wieder kommt?
Teaching for Empowerment genau. Und da habe ich lange drüber nachgedacht, wie wir eigentlich ein Lernprogramm dafür gestalten könnten, in dem das passiert. Und ein anderer Gesichtspunkt sozusagen bei der Überlegung, wie wir dieses Lernprogramm geboren wurde, das kam durchaus aus dem Medienhintergrund. Wenn Sie gucken einen Film, zum Beispiel einen James Bond Film 007, was können Sie als Zuschauer da machen? Sie können sich eigentlich nur den angucken und sich mit der Hauptperson identifizieren. Das heißt die Interaktionsmöglichkeiten, die Handlungsmöglichkeiten für Sie sind relativ beschränkt. Sie können den Film auch noch ausstellen, wenn er Sie nervt. Das geht aber weiter, wenn Sie gucken in den 90ern, wenn Sie gucken was alles entstanden ist an Computerspielen. Da haben ja die Leute, die Computerspiele machen, erst alleine vorm Rechner gesessen. Dann gab es die serverbasierten Spiele, wo Leute zusammenspielen. Dinge wie World of Warcraft heute. Dann ist es weitergegangen in Richtung eigentlich in den Real World Locationbased Games, wie Schottland Yard Games in einer realen Umgebung, wie zum Beispiel in London.
Wo Sie über Smartphones mit einem Server verbunden sind, und Leute tatsächlich da einen virtuellen Verbrecher, einen Mitspieler im Spiel jagen. Und da entstand so die Überlegung draus, wie wäre das denn, dass wir diese Lust von Leuten eigentlich zu spielen und der Held zu sein in ihrer eigenen Geschichte, das ist nämlich das, was sie sowohl sind bei James Bond, wenn Sie sich mit dem James Bond da identifizieren, dann sind Sie eigentlich der Held. Und dasselbe sind Sie in diesen Egoshooter-Games. Oder dasselbe sind Sie, wenn Sie der Verfolger des Täters sind in so einem Schottland Yard Game. Wenn wir das in die reale Welt übertragen, wenn wir eigentlich eine Umgebung schaffen, wo Leute auf einmal zum Held ihrer eigenen Geschichte werden, aber was reales machen in der Welt. Wenn sie ein reales Problem lösen. Und wie eine Medienumgebung bauen und eine reale Umgebung mit Unterstützungsmaßnahmen wie Kursen, reale Meetups, Beratungsmöglichkeiten, aber halt auch natürlich das Mediennetz.
Was über soziale Medien geht, was über eine Lernplattform integriert ist, wo das möglich wird. Und so ist die Idee zu dem Projekt YOOWEEDOO, dem Lernprogramm für Zukunftsmacher entstanden.
Man wird hier sozusagen zum Geheimagenten zur Weltrettung ausgebildet?
Ja ich will nicht sagen, zum geheimen Agenten, denn die Sachen sind ja alle sehr real. Aber man wird ausgebildet, der eigene Held seiner Ideen zu werden. Dass man lernt, dass es nicht bleibt bei dieser Überlegung, ach man sollte doch mal was tun, hier ist was nicht okay in der Welt. Ob das was soziales ist oder im Umweltbereich, das geht eigentlich allen so, dass man doch viele Sachen sieht im Alltag, wo man denkt, ach das ist nicht gut so. Eigentlich müsste ich mal was tun. Und das Programm ist dafür gedacht, dass Menschen/Studierende lernen, wie komme ich aus diesem, man sollte eigentlich mal was tun, dahin, den Schritt zu machen, ich mach es jetzt. Und ich weiß, wie ich es mache, kognitiv und ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass ich das kann.
Also passt ja Agent eigentlich wunderbar. Das heißt ja im Prinzip genau, wie man agiert sozusagen.
Agent ja, sollten wir uns mal überlegen, ist eine gute Idee.
Ja handeln.
Geheimagent nicht ganz, aber Agent ja.
Das geheim war wahrscheinlich unpassend, aber Agenten entstehen hier schon.
Ja. Und so ist das halt ursprünglich entstanden das Programm. Und das ist jetzt so um 2010 rum war das.
Genau. Ein Programm, was ich so jetzt noch gar nicht konkret erwähnt hatte, ich wollte mich da noch so ein bisschen mal anpirschen. Also wir befinden uns hier bei Geografie und Medien, aber in gewisser Hinsicht ist das so eine Tarnorganisation für sozialen Wandel. Das steht hier sozusagen im Mittelpunkt.
Also ich hoffe, dass jetzt mein Präsidium nicht mithört.
Nein niemals. Ja aber ich meine, das ist ja auch sichtbar. Also wenn ich es richtig verstehe, dann geht es hier im Prinzip nicht nur darum, die Welt zu kartografieren, und darüber zu berichten, sondern Geografie und Medien ich deute das mal so ein bisschen um so in Weltverständnis und Kommunikation zusammenzubringen. Kann man das sagen?
Na das ist mir jetzt fast zu kurz gesprungen. Also ich will, also mein Ziel ist, dass Leute bei uns lernen in den Kursen, aber auch mit den Online-Dingen, die wir machen, wie sie aus einer Idee für eine Sache, die sie verändern wollen auf der Welt mit einer positiven Auswirkung auch für die Gesellschaft, wie sie von dieser Idee zu einem wirklich durchgeplanten Projekt kommen und dann wie sie dieses Projekt umsetzen können. Weil viel zu viele Sachen hören bei diesem Konzept auf, wir machen mal ein Konzept. Also das passiert ja täglich in der Uni. Und dann passiert nichts weiter. Dann wird die Hausarbeit benotet und entsorgt. Und wir denken und wir wissen auch aus den Erfahrungen der ganzen Jahre, dass es total entscheidend ist, dass Leute das umsetzen, und zwar mit voller Verantwortung. Also dass nicht der Professor oder so die Verantwortung hat, sondern nein die Studierenden müssen die selber haben, damit sie die Erfahrung machen sozusagen, ich kann das. Weil wenn man die Erfahrung macht, ich kann was verändern, dann wird man das immer wieder machen.
Also das sehen wir auch an den Teilnehmern der frühen Jahrgänge, die machen eins nach dem anderen. Also manche gehen weiter, dass sie aus einem kleinen Projekt einen Verein, eine Organisation oder auch eine Firma gründen. Manche sagen, ich habe bei diesem ersten Projekt viel gelernt, jetzt mach ich was neues, plane das professioneller und mache eine Firma draus.
Stand das gleich am Anfang sozusagen hier der neuen Professur in Kiel oder ist das auch etwas, was sich nochmal hat entwickeln müssen?
Nein das hat sich auch entwickeln müssen. Also die Professur, ich muss jetzt selber nachdenken wie lange ich hier bin, ich glaube seit 2001/02 und na wie gesagt, das Zukunftsmacher oder wie man auf Englisch sagt, das Changemaker-Programm ist erst so gegen 2010 entstanden. Und ja ich musste mich da auch rantasten. Ich habe am Anfang eigentlich das, was ich auch dem Medienbereich selber wusste versucht in Kurse zu packen. Und irgendwann hat man dann …
wie die schon erwähnte Videoproduktion zum Beispiel.
Videoproduktion das machen wir auch weiter. Aber irgendwann merkt man für sich selber, dass es eigentlich den Kern von … man fragt sich, ist das jetzt der Kern von mir, was ich hier beitragen will und kann? Ist es das? Will ich bis zu meiner Rente weiter Videokurse geben? Oder  ist es eigentlich was anderes? Und ich glaube für mich ist die Frage ganz eindeutig, das war dann so um 2010 rum, dass ich dachte, eigentlich ich kann Dinge verändern, ich kann das auch gut planen, ich kann auch sehen wie Dinge und Personen zusammenkommen könnten, die es vielleicht heute gibt, um gemeinsam was zu machen. Und das ist das, was ich in so ein Lernprogramm verpacken möchte, weil ich glaube, dass das was ist, was viele Leute lernen sollten, damit sie selber damit arbeiten können. Und so ist das halt von der Zeit, es sind 7-8 Jahre vergangen von der Anstellung hier an der Uni bis zum Start von dem Zukunftsmacher-Programm.
Ich fasse das mal so in meinen Worten zusammen. Diese ganze Erfahrung, über die wir jetzt schon viel gesprochen haben, hat quasi den Wunsch hervor gebracht, nicht nur plakativ und theoretisch zu bleiben, sondern sozusagen so ein umfassendes Changemanagement beizubringen und das auch so konkret mit diesem unternehmerischen Unterton auch. Also dass man nicht nur theoretisch lernt, was getan werden müsste, sondern dass man wirklich das in Schritte aufdröselt und dann sagt, okay jetzt versuche ich hier mal ein konkretes Ziel anzustreben und der Unterricht konzentriert sich quasi auf die einzelnen Phasen auf dem Weg dahin?
Für mich war immer ein Motiv dessen was ich gemacht habe im Leben die Frage, wie kann ich Dinge sinnvoll verändern auf der Welt. Das war damals, als ich angefangen habe Biologie zu studieren, das war beim Zivildienst vorher schon, das war als ich dann das Programm hatte, wo ich mich in der Master- und der Doktorarbeit mit der Kartierung von Regenwaldvernichtung beschäftigt habe. Und das war halt auch hier an der Professur ist es für mich ein Leitmotiv geworden. Und ich glaube diese Frage, die hat mich immer bewegt, wie kann ich lernen und anderen vermitteln, selber was zu verändern auf der Welt. Die ist eigentlich so ein bisschen mein Kern, und die habe ich versucht in ein Lernprogramm zu packen. Und unternehmerisch, wenn Sie sagen unternehmerisch,  es ist gar nicht so gemeint, dass wir wollen, dass alle Leute hier eine Firma gründen, das tun eine ganze Reihe, aber unternehmerisch verstehe ich eigentlich so, dass man eigentlich in die Lage kommt, selber was unternehmen zu können.
Dass man sozusagen selber weiß, wie ich was planen kann, was umsetzen kann, was verändern kann, ein Projekt machen, ein wachstumsfähiges Projekt, vielleicht eine Organisation aufbauen und so weiter, das meine ich mit unternehmerisch.
Ja, es gibt ja auch diesen relativ neuen Begriff des social Entrepreneurship, das geht ja so ein bisschen in die Richtung, also soziales Unternehmertum, passt das hier rein der Begriff?
Absolut. Also als ich das Programm angefangen habe zu planen, da habe ich eine ganze Reihe Dinge gesehen im Netz, gelesen über social Entrepreneurship, weil das ist diese generelle Frage, wie kann man Dinge verändern auf der Welt? Ja Organisationen wie Greenpeace sagen, über Campagning und über Lobbying. Man kann auch in die Politik gehen, man geht zu den Grünen und sagt, das mach ich direkt als Politiker. Man kann aber auch eine Firma gründen und sagt, Politik ist nicht meine Welt, ich mache eine Firma, die aus sich selbst finanziell wachstumsfähig ist, um Dinge verändern zu können. Und wenn Sie diese Frage stellen, eigentlich wie kann ich bottom-up was verändern? Dann startet das eigentlich immer mit der Frage, wie kann ich ein erstes Projekt machen? Und social Entrepreneurship verbindet das mit der Frage, wie kann ich denn die Projektstrategie so planen, dass da ein Geschäfts- oder Finanzierungsmodell in so einem Projekt mit drin ist.
Damit wenn das Projekt gut ist, wenn das tatsächlich eine reale Wirkung hat, einen realen Impact in der Welt, dass es auch wachsen kann, damit mehr Leute davon was haben. Und da sehe ich den Kern von social Entrepreneurship. Und das ist natürlich so ein Kerngedanke auch in unserem Lernprogramm.
Also sozusagen Unternehmertum, aber mit anderen Primärzielen so?
Ja genau, also das Unternehmertum, aber nicht mit dem Primärziel wie eine Aktiengesellschaft, den Wert meiner Aktien und den Gewinn für die Aktionäre zu vermehren. Sondern Unternehmertum mit dem Primärzweck eigentlich, gesellschaftliche Anliegen damit zu bearbeiten und zu lösen. Und natürlich müssen sich solche Modell finanzieren, sonst hängen sie ewig ab von Spendern oder Stiftungen oder Fördermittelanträgen. Das heißt dass man von Anfang an eigentlich versucht, in so eine Lösungsstrategie für ein Umweltproblem oder ein gesellschaftliches soziales Problem ein Finanzierungsmodell einzuplanen. Das ist der Kern von social Entrepreneurship.
Es kam dann halt zu der konkreten Benennung, das ist jetzt auch schon ein paar mal gefallen, vielleicht können wir die Begriffe nochmal kurz bisschen auseinander sortieren. Also es gibt da einerseits das Projekt YOOWEEDOO und dann fiel jetzt  auch nochmal der Begriff Changemaker, bzw. die Zukunftsmacher-Plattform, wie hängen die Begriffe zusammen, nur damit wir das verstehen?
Also Sie haben ja selber schon gesagt social Entrepreneurship und die Organisation, die weltweit eigentlich dieses Feld am meisten vorangebracht hat in den letzten 25-30 Jahren, ist eine amerikanische Organisation Ashoka nennt die sich, die hat halt den Begriff der Changemaker eigentlich aufgebracht. Also Changemaker als Menschen, die Veränderung machen. Dafür gibt es natürlich kein wirklich gutes deutsche Komplement, keine wirklich gute Übersetzung. Und wir fanden das von der Intension, vom Sinn her am nächsten ist der Begriff Zukunftsmacher. Und das ist so, also deswegen manchmal, wenn wir im internationalen Kontext sind, wir haben ja auch internationale Studierende hier, dann reden wir von Changemaker und wenn wir uns an ein deutsches Publikum wenden, deutsche Studierende, aber auch Öffentlichkeit, dann reden wir von Zukunftsmachern. Aber das ist eigentlich synonym für uns.
Okay.
Und jetzt die Frage nach YOOWEEDOO, wir brauchten natürlich für so ein Projekt einen Namen und dann ist immer die Frage, ist das jetzt ein Name, der generisch ist oder reicht uns Zukunftsmacher aus? Aber das benutzen zu viele Menschen, für teilweise auch unterschiedliche Dinge. Und wir haben einfach gesagt, wir kombinieren das mit einem Namen für das Projekt, der einfach unique, der eindeutig ist und YOOWEEDOO haben wir gewählt deswegen, weil es heißt, you have an idea, du hast eine Idee, we support you, wir unterstützen dich, do it, mach es jetzt endlich, so kam YOOWEEDOO zusammen. Und der Name hat sich sehr gut etabliert, also in der Szene, dass uns eigentlich die meisten darunter gut finden. Und wir kombinieren das dann je nach Zielgruppe, ob die deutsch oder englischsprachig eher ist, mit dem Begriff Zukunftsmacher oder Changemaker. Weil wir sowohl deutsche als auch internationale Zielgruppen haben.
Das heißt die Zukunftsmacher-Plattform, die es ja auch gibt, unter Zukunftsmacher-Plattform.org, fungiert als Informationsplattform primär?
Die Zukunftsmacher-Plattform haben wir gegründet als Lernplattform. Also unser Ziel, da muss ich einen Moment ausholen, unser Ziel war immer, dass wir eigentlich denken, alle Leute, alle jungen Leute, aber auch eigentlich darüber hinaus alle Leute sollten wissen, wie sie von einer Idee für eine bessere Welt zu einem realen Projekt kommen. Sonst wird die Welt nämlich nicht besser, sonst bleiben das immer nur Ideen. Und viel davon kann man lernen. Und natürlich können wir über die Kurse, wo Studenten physisch hinkommen hier an der Universität Kiel natürlich nur eine begrenzte Zahl von Menschen erreichen. Und deswegen kam die Idee, dass wir sagten, wir versuchen das Ganze in ein Onlinekurs zu packen, den wir auch gemacht haben. 2013 haben wir damit angefangen, hat der Stifterverband uns ermöglicht mit einer Finanzierung, dass wir den Kurs, wie plane ich denn überhaupt so ein Projekt? Der Kurs reicht von der ersten Ideenfindung bis zu einem detailliert ausgeplanten Projektkonzept für ein Veränderungsprojekt.
Da haben wir einen videobasierten Onlinekurs gemacht, die damals also in Mode kamen unter dem Label MOOC, massive open online courses, der Kurs nennt sich der Changemaker-MOOC. Und an dem haben tatsächlich inzwischen über 15.000 Leute teilgenommen, also man sieht sozusagen, dass diese Medien natürlich einem das ermöglichen, einfach einen viel größeren Teilnehmerkreis zu erreichen. Wir haben den MOOC dann erst auf einer kommerziellen Onlinelearning-Plattform laufen lassen, 2013. Haben dann aber sehr schnell gesehen, das hat Vor- und Nachteile. Vorteile sind, die Plattform an sich hat eine große Reichweite, Nachteil ist, wir kommen an die Adressdaten der Teilnehmer nicht dran in unserem eigenen Kurs. Und wir haben gemerkt, dass also in vielen anderen Städten in Deutschland, da gibt es vereinzelte Teilnehmer an so einem Kurs, und die haben ein großes Interesse daran, eigentlich untereinander lokal in Kontakt zu kommen. Das können wir aber nicht vermitteln, weil wir die Adressen nicht kriegen, weil das eine kommerzielle Plattform ist.
Genau es geht ja nicht nur um den eigentlichen Kurs, es geht ja auch um die Community, die dadurch entstehen kann.
Genau und das war eigentlich der Hauptbeweggrund für uns zu sagen, wir brauchen eine eigene Lernplattform und Kommunikationsplattform, die sich auf diesen Bereich der Changemaker/Zukunftsmacher fokussiert. Lernangebote für die bereitstellt, aber ihnen gleichzeitig eben ermöglicht, wie so eine Art Mini-Facebook, untereinander ein eigenes Profil zu haben, miteinander in den Austausch zu kommen. Es gibt ein Blog darauf, wo wir Nachrichten reinposten, die interessant sind für diese Zielgruppe. Das ist die Zukunftsmacher-Plattform. Und die ist auch tatsächlich offen auch für andere Hochschulen zu nutzen. Wir hatten ein weiteres Problem, weil wir wollten mit Universitäten in anderen Städten zusammenarbeiten, anderen Bundesländern. Und an der Uni Kiel war es nicht möglich, dass Studenten von anderen Hochschulen unser Online-Lernsystem an der Uni Kiel benutzen. Weil die einfach sagen, das geht nur für Studierende der Uni Kiel und Mitarbeiter der Uni Kiel und wer anders kommt da nicht rein.
Aus IT-Sicherheitsgründen. Dasselbe Problem, dann hatten wir Partner in Bayern, die sagten, ja virtuelle Hochschule Bayern, aber da dürfen, weil das aus dem bayrischen Landeshaushalt finanziert wird, ist die Plattform nur offen für Studierende an bayrischen Hochschulen. Also immer diese ganze Kleinstaaterei. Und dann habe wir gesagt, nein wir machen jetzt eine eigene Plattform, an die kann sich jeder einloggen, der das möchte. Wir können zusammenarbeiten mit Studierenden von egal welcher Hochschule. Die Plattform ist auch so, die hat ein deutsches Interface, lässt sich aber umschalten auf englisch, auch den Changemaker-MOOC gibt es auf deutsch und englisch, so dass man einfach sehr breit arbeiten kann mit Partnern da zusammen.
Was ist daraus entstanden?
Also um den Changemaker-MOOC rum passierte was, womit wir gar nicht geplant hatten, gar nicht gerechnet hatten. Das ging also, als der erste Durchlauf startete, und auf einmal waren da 3000-4000 Leute, die also in diesem Kurs studierten. Das hat uns komplett überwältigt muss ich sagen, auch personell, auf Sachen zu antworten, hat uns echt gebunden.
Wo kamen die denn alle so schnell her?
Also das wurde …
Ich meine 4000 Leute ansprechen gelingt einem ja auch nicht immer so vom Anfang weg.
Also am Schluss waren es dann sogar 8000. Aber das war, also diese Plattform hatte ja 10 MOOCs weltweit sind da gefördert worden, die Produktionen vom Stifterverband und wurden dann natürlich sehr breit beworben, und auf einmal waren da also auch MOOCs, die hatten dann zigtausend von Leuten. Also da hatten wir alle nicht mit gerechnet, was da passiert in dem Moment.
Sind zumindest ihrem Namen mal gerecht geworden. Auf einmal wurde es halt wirklich massiv.
Ja, wir fühlten uns von der Massivität fast überrannt. Und was aber interessant war, es sind so das erste Dutzend Kolleginnen und Kollegen von anderen Hochschulen auf uns zugekommen, die sagten, boah das ist ja interessant, gibt es das denn nächstes Jahr wieder? Und aus diesem Kolleginnen- und Kollegenkreis, inzwischen sind es gut zwei Dutzend Kolleginnen und Kollegen an anderen Hochschulen hier in Deutschland verstreut, inzwischen auch in Österreich, teilweise in der Schweiz, ist sowas wie ein loses Netzwerk entstanden von Personen, die eigentlich Interesse haben, ihren Studenten in Kursen an ihren Hochschulen zu ermöglichen, eigene Changeprojekte, Veränderungsprojekte, Nachhaltigkeitsprojekte zu planen und die dann auch umzusetzen. Und das passiert an allen Hochschulen unterschiedlich. Aber wir haben wie gesagt in der Mitte so die Zukunftsmacher-Plattform, die halt als Open Educational Ressources von allen kostenfrei und offen genutzt werden kann.
Und was ist nun, in welchem Verhältnis steht nun die YOOWEEDOO-Plattform dazu?
YOOWEEDOO ist eigentlich, also Sie meinen jetzt die Webadresse YOOWEEDOO.org?
Ja genau.
YOOWEEDOO.org erzählt eigentlich nur auf wenigen Seiten was YOOWEEDOO ist. Aber das ganze Eigentliche, was man für seine Kurse nutzen kann oder was man als jemand, der ein Projekt planen möchte, nutzen kann, das befindet sich alles auf der Zukunftsmacher-Plattform. Und wir haben die auch ich muss sagen extra auch nicht nach YOOWEEDOO benannt, weil wir dachten, es ist wichtig, dass die also nicht mit dem Label unseres Projektes gebrandet ist, sondern dass es eher als offener Service auch, weil es eine Open Educational Ressources ist, für andere als Dienstleistung auch betrachtet wird. Es geht da zum Beispiel so weit, dass Sie wenn Sie zum Beispiel Dozent sind, keine Ahnung, an der Humboldt-Uni in Berlin und Sie haben da einen Kurs, Sie wollen Informationen posten auf der Community-Blogseite, die auch für Studierende oder auch für Teilnehmer in anderen Bundesländern interessant sind, Sie haben vielleicht eine interessante Veranstaltung, einen Workshop, den Sie anbieten, das können Sie alles direkt darauf machen, ohne dass das bei uns durch die Redaktion geht.
Also jeder, der sich da anmeldet, kann das für seine Zwecke einsetzen.
Das heißt das Ziel ist vor allem also, sowohl natürlich hier an der Uni Kiel etwas zu bewirken und das passiert wohl auch, aber es eben von vornherein auch als Werkzeug für andere Universitäten auch bereitzustellen, so dass das Rad nicht nochmal erfunden werden muss?
Genau.
Das ist eine Einladung oder?
Das ist eine Einladung ja. Und wir haben auch über Netzwerke, wie zum Beispiel es gibt das Hochschulnetzwerk Bildung durch Verantwortung, wo mehrere Dutzend Hochschulen und Universitäten sich bundesweit zusammengeschlossen haben, die interessiert sind an diesem Service-Learning-Bereich, da sind wir auch Mitglied. Und wir führen regelmäßig da auf den Tagungen Einführungsworkshops durch und das geht dann darüber hinaus, dass wir diejenigen, die sagen, ich möchte das nicht mal nur sporadisch nutzen, sondern ich möchte wirklich so ein eigenes Changemaker-Lernprogramm bei mir aufbauen, dass wir die in einem sogenannten Changeleader-Programm dabei unterstützen. Also wir beraten die, wie sie das an ihrer Hochschule machen können, wie sie Ressourcen, die wir haben, wie sie die Zukunftsmacher-Plattform dafür nutzen können. Sie können von uns Unterlagen bekommen zu Prüfungsformaten, Workshop-Formaten, wie werden die Workshops durchgeführt. Also das stellen wir alles kostenfrei zur Verfügung. Und wir haben jetzt eine Zusammenarbeit mit den ersten Hochschulen, wo wir das also im Detail machen.
Das ist die katholische Universität Eichstätt und die Hochschule für nachhaltige Entwicklung in Eberswalde, mit denen wir im Herbst auch Social Innovation Camps machen werden, wo also Projektideen entwickelt werden mit den Studenten, die wir durchführen zusammen mit den Partnern an den Hochschulen, wo wir in dem Kontext alle eigentlich voneinander lernen können. Und gleichzeitig beraten wir dann die Hochschulen, wie sie so ein eigenes Lernprogramm bei sich aufstellen können.
Und haben das auch schon einige in Anspruch genommen?
Also dieses Jahr das Programm führen wir jetzt im Herbst das erste Mal durch. Das finanziert die Bundesstiftung Umwelt. Und wir machen den ersten Durchlauf jetzt. Wir haben auch schon gestartet, wir machen es nicht nur mit Hochschulen, wir machen es auch mit Nichtregierungsorganisationen, wie zum Beispiel Viva con Agua, da haben wir auch schone einen Testlauf, der läuft. Weil wir betrachten eigentlich Hochschulen als einen Kanal, wie wir die Zielgruppe junge Leute, die was verändern wollen, erreichen können. Die können sie aber auch über andere Organisationen, wie zum Beispiel Viva con Agua erreichen, eine NGO, die in dem Bereich weltweit unterwegs ist, wie können wir allen Menschen auf dieser Welt Zugang zu sauberem Trinkwasser und zu sauberen Toiletten ermöglichen. Und da sind auch eben viele tausend Mitglieder, ist auch ein interessanter letzten Endes Kanal, um an die Zielgruppe dran zu kommen. Also man kann das online machen, man kann das über eine NGO machen, man kann das über eine andere Hochschule machen und wir sind auf unterschiedlichen Feldern aktiv.
Und wer ist dann die Zielgruppe?
Die Zielgruppe. Also unsere Kernzielgruppe sind junge Menschen zwischen 20 und 30.
Die also noch nicht mal zwangsläufig jetzt Studenten sein müssen?
Die müssen nicht zwangsläufig Studenten sein, wir haben natürlich, weil wir in diesen Hochschulkontext eingebettet sind, vorwiegend Studierende, aber es müssen nicht nur Studierende sein. Also zum Beispiel in der Zusammenarbeit mit Viva con Agua erreichen wir auch Leute, die keine Studierenden sind. Wird auch von der Bundesstiftung Umwelt explizit gewünscht und gefördert.
Also nur zum Verständnis, es geht nicht nur darum, jetzt sozusagen Leute, die ohnehin an Hochschulen sind, hier irgendwie einzubinden, sondern es geht darum, alle einzubinden, die sich einbinden lassen wollen?
Ich würde sagen, primär fokussieren wir uns einfach aus logistischen Gründen auf Hochschulen. Und wir sind jetzt dabei einen zweiten Kanal aufzubauen über die Zusammenarbeit mit NGOs.
Okay. Könnte ja dann sozusagen das Feld auch nochmal etwas diversifizieren, auch nochmal einen ganz anderen Ideenkanal gebären.
Ja also wir lernen dabei ja auch viel dazu über die Jahre. Wir machen das jetzt im siebten Jahr. Unser Lernprogramm ist eigentlich weitgehend also sehr ausgereift inzwischen. Wir haben sieben Jahren Erfahrung, über 700 Leute, die wir tatsächlich in Präsenzkursen gehabt haben hier an der Uni. Aber halt viele tausend weitere, wo wir dann auch Teilnehmerbefragungen machen aus dem Online-Bereich. Funktionieren unsere Online-Angebote für die, wünschen die sich was anderes, muss das anders aufbereitet werden? Und diese Art Sachen. Also wir haben eine Menge Erfahrungen, mit denen wir Kolleginnen und Kollegen an anderen Hochschulen unterstützen können. Ich will nicht sagen, dass wir jedes Problem lösen können, aber die wir gern verfügbar machen, wenn andere was planen wollen.
Um es vielleicht mal ein bisschen konkreter zu machen, mich würde mal, wenn es jetzt auch schon so viele Erfahrungen gibt, so ein bisschen interessieren, wo ich jetzt so durchlaufen könnte. Also wie quasi diese Kurse auf mich jetzt wirken, wenn ich jetzt bereit wäre, bin ich auch grundsätzlich, Änderungen herbeizuführen. Und jetzt komm ich mit einer Idee in diese Plattform? Kommt die Plattform mit einer Idee für mich? Finde ich dort überhaupt erst meine Idee? Können wir vielleicht mal so ein Beispiel rausgreifen, was auch schon mal so passiert ist? Um auch zu verstehen, wie eigentlich dieser Unterricht strukturiert ist.
Also das sind ja zwei Fragen. Ich antworte erst mal darauf, wie eigentlich das Programm strukturiert ist. Ich nehme erst mal den Standardfall, es findet hier bei uns in der Uni Kiel statt. Also
wir haben im Wintersemester einen Kurs, der läuft von Ende Oktober bis Ende Januar, wo der Studierende da eingebettet ist, teilweise in die deutschsprachigen Bachelor, zum Beispiel Geografie oder über das Zentrum für Schlüsselqualifikationen hochschulweit auch zugäugig ist. Und wir haben dasselbe auch eingebettet in die internationalen Masterstudiengänge der School of Sustainability. Und da lernt man, wie plane ich ein Nachhaltigkeitsprojekt oder ein sozialunternehmerisches Vorhaben. Und die Leute ist meine Erfahrung kommen meistens in diese Kurse rein mit einem Interesse, aber noch keiner konkreten Projektidee. Das heißt wir fangen eigentlich an dem Punkt an, wo die Leute sagen, ich würde gerne was, ich möchte was mit Flüchtlingen machen oder ich möchte was zum Thema Nahrungsmittelverschwendung machen oder Ressourcenschutz und dann entwickeln wir erst eine Projektidee mit den Teilnehmern zusammen.
Und diese Ideen entwickeln die Teilnehmer selber. Weil ich denke, es ist ganz wichtig, dass Leute erst ein Problem eigentlich analysieren, wie man das so im Hochschulbereich ja auch tut. Aber dann halt sozusagen einen Lösungsansatz, im Sinne von Think global act local, dass man einen lokalen Handlungsansatz plant und dann haben wir eine Phase, die nennen wir immer Umfeldanalyse, wo dann die Teams, das passiert in kleinen Teams von 3-5 Studenten, die so ein Projekt planen, sich dann in Verbindung setzen mit lauter lokalen Akteuren, also zum Beispiel in den Flüchtlingsorganisationen oder je nachdem wer für dieses Projekt interessant ist, wo wir dann Kontakte mit helfen herzustellen, damit das alles schneller geht. Aber wo die im Prinzip gucken sozusagen, was gibt es denn für Angebote in diesem Bereich schon? Versuchen wir hier was zu planen, was sowieso schon existiert? Oder wird vielleicht was ganz anderes gebraucht? Was sagt denn unsere Zielgruppe dazu? Finden denn Flüchtlinge, dass sie so was überhaupt brauchen? Oder haben die da eh keinen Bock drauf?
Also das ist in dieser Phase 2, das passiert normalerweise im November/Dezember. Und dann, wenn es eine Projektidee gibt, wo wir denken, so die hat Realisierungspotenzial, dann wird im Prinzip klassisch einfach ein Projekt geplant, also mit Aktivitätenplanung, Projektstruktur, Kostenplanung. Dann wird ein Finanzierungsmodell dazu geplant und das Ganze endet dann Ende Januar, dass ein detailliert ausgearbeitet Projektkonzept vorliegt, was wirklich professionell geplant ist. Und wir orientieren uns dabei an einem Berichtsformat, was in dieser sozialunternehmerischen social Entrepreneurship-Szene so zum Standard wird. Das nennt sich der Social Reporting Standard. Ist auch von Ashoka mit entwickelt. Könnte ich mehr zu erzählen. Aber wir haben dann zum 01. Februar die Möglichkeit sich mit seinem Projektkonzept bei uns im Ideenwettbewerb um Startkapital zu bewerben und ein Projekt kann maximal 2000 Euro bekommen.
Und diese Projekte sind im Wintersemester immer so geplant, dass man sie im Sommersemester umsetzen kann als Piloten. Das heißt es sollte nicht mehr als 25-30% der Studienzeit eines Semesters so beanspruchen. Es sollte sich umsetzen lassen als Pilot mit geringen Ressourcen mit einem Team von 3-5 Studierenden. Die Studenten müssen was planen, wo also wir ganz klar sagen, was sind die Anforderungen an Projekte, weil wir ja die Themen nicht vorgeben. Aber wir haben trotzdem natürlich Anforderungen. Und die Anforderungen sind sehr simpel. Wir sagen, es soll in irgendeiner Form zu nachhaltiger Entwicklung beitragen. Und ihr müsst uns erklären, in welcher Form das passieren soll. Das zweite ist, es muss ganz klar sein, ihr müsst uns erklären, welchen Mehrwert hat die Gesellschaft davon, dass ihr dieses Projekt umsetzt und ihr müsst uns erklären können, welche Wirkung soll das haben. Nicht nur, dass ihr ein Projekt gemacht habt sozusagen, sondern was wird dieses Projekt wirklich auf der Welt verbessern?
Die dritte Anforderung ist, dass wir sagen, wir wollen, dass die Studenten, die das machen, 100% voll verantwortlich sind. Also wir fördern im Ideenwettbewerb und wir lassen auch vorher im Projektplanungskurs keine Projekte entwickeln, wo die Studenten nicht 100% selbst verantwortlich sind, alle Entscheidungen auch selber treffen. Weil dieses selber die Verantwortung haben eben total entscheidend dafür ist, dass man hinterher das Gefühl hat sozusagen, wer ist denn dafür verantwortlich, wenn das Projekt ein großer Erfolg wird oder wenn man es vor die Wand gefahren hat. Dass man dann nicht sagen kann, das war aber dieser Prof., der hat da was gesagt. Das war der Corves, der hat gesagt, ich soll das so und so machen. Nein, da ist ganz klar, ich bin hier nur Berater, planen tut ihr und entscheiden tut ihr auch. Und das gilt natürlich auch für die ganzen … der Wettbewerb, der dann kommt im Februar/März, der ist bundesweit ausgeschrieben, da haben sich dieses Jahr über 70 Projektteams beworben und wir haben 34 fördern können mit bis zu 2000 Euro jeweils, knapp 60000 Euro ausschütten können, die von unterschiedlichsten Förderern wieder kommen.
Und dann geht das ab Anfang April, so ab Ostern, in die Zeit, wo die Pilotprojekte umgesetzt werden. Und dann in der Zeit hat natürlich jedes Team sein eigenes Projekt. Die Kieler Projekte, wir haben immer so an die 15 hier in der Region, sind natürlich über uns gut vernetzt. Aber bundesweit haben wir weitere 20 Projekte, die oft dann alleine sind in der Stadt, wo sie ihr Projekt umsetzen. Und Stichwort Community, was Sie vorhin nannten, es ist also sozusagen nicht alleine zu sein mit dieser Art Vorhaben, sondern zu merken, da gibt es viele andere, die auch solche Sachen machen, das ist ganz wichtig. Und wir haben jedes Jahr im Mai ein großes Summer Camp, wo wir alle Projekte einladen für vier Tage nach Sylt. Hatten wir jetzt gerade wieder, wo dann 70-80 hochmotivierte richtig fitte Leute zusammenkommen und daran arbeiten, gemeinsam ihre Projekte weiterzuentwickeln. An Dingen arbeiten, wie Geschäftsmodell überarbeiten. Wir haben dann Berater, zum Beispiel einen Anwalt, der für sozialunternehmerische Startups für Rechtsformen Spezialist ist.
Wir haben Leute aus dem Marketingbereich. Wir laden Projekte ein, die schon 2-3 Jahre älter sind, dass man sehen kann, auf was für Probleme stößt man vielleicht, wenn man so ein Projekt in ein Unternehmen weiterentwickelt oder in eine Organisation wie einen Verein. Wir haben erfahrene Coaches, die Projekte individuell beraten und so weiter und das passiert im Mai. Und zwischendurch sozusagen sind wir natürlich über das ganze Sommersemester immer verfügbar, wenn da Fragen zu den Projekten selber auftauchen. Und so das ist dieser Standardablauf, der läuft  halt einmal über ein Jahr. Wintersemester Projekte planen, Ideenwettbewerb, Startup-Kapital versuchen zu kriegen von uns und dann im Sommer Projekte umsetzen. Und in dieser Umsetzungsphase gucken wir, welche Projekte möglicherweise ein Weiterentwicklungspotenzial haben. Dass man sagt, wir denken euer Projekt und euer Team ihr habt das Potenzial, dass man eine Organisation draus entwickeln könnte.
Oder vielleicht auch ein Unternehmen. Das ist jetzt eigentlich falsch rum gesagt, weil meistens kommen die auf uns selber zu und dann gucken wir, welche Möglichkeiten es gibt, das für die einzelnen Teams zu erreichen. Das sind je nach Jahr ein Viertel oder ein Drittel ungefähr der Teams, die hinterher in eine Gründung gehen.
Gibt es da mal so ein konkretes Beispiel, was da so diesen Prozess mehr oder weniger erfolgreich durchlaufen hat und was da Umsatz und Wirkung war?
Ja, also zum Beispiel wir haben – ich nehme mal eins unserer führen Projekte, das jetzt schon ein bisschen paar Jahre älter ist – ist das Projekt Goldeimer. Da war von einem Studenten hier in Kiel auch im Bachelor eine Bachelor-Arbeit geschrieben worden zu Komposttoiletten. Und normalerweise schreibt man dann eine Arbeit über Komposttoiletten. Die Idee kam ursprünglich aus dem afrikanischen Kontext. Da werden Komposttoiletten oft in Slums eingesetzt, weil es ja keine Kanalisation gibt. Also von Entwicklungsorganisationen. Und die Frage tauchte dann auf, und darüber hat er in seiner Bachelorarbeit gearbeitet, wie könnte man denn sozusagen dieses Konzept eigentlich in Deutschland anwenden, weil was wir hier machen eigentlich mit Toiletten, dass wir das Ganze also dann wegspülen und eigentlich ein Entsorgungsproblem schaffen dadurch, was wir dann über Kläranlagen wieder versuchen zu lösen. Aber jeder, der an der Ostsee ist, weiß, dass das nur zur Hälfte gelingt, weil die Ostsee komplett überdüngt ist durch häusliche Abwässer, aber auch …
Agrar.
Abfluss von Agrargebieten. Und daraus entstand die Idee zu sagen, junge Leute in den Anfängen ihrer 20er, Mitte 20, die kennen die Situation auf großen Musikfestivals wie Wacken, aber auch viele andere, wo diese elenden Dixi-Toiletten sind, die tatsächlich ja fast Sondermüll sind durch diese Chemikalien. Kann man nicht einfach mal in die Toilette schütten hinterher, weil das die Kläranlagen abschießt. Und die Überlegung war, wie könnte man eigentlich ein Komposttoilettensystem für Festivals entwickeln? Die Bachelor-Arbeit war fertig, dann haben die bei uns in dem Projektplanungskurs den Plan entwickelt, das Konzept entwickelt für einen ersten Piloten mit zwei Toiletten. Komposttoiletten für lokale Musikfestivals, um das Konzept zu testen. Und auch um zu testen, wie sind die Festivalbetreiber, wie stehen die dazu? Nehmen die Festivalbesucher das an? Wie ist die "willingness to pay"? Was wären Leute bereit, für ihren Toilettenbesuch zu zahlen?
Kann man daraus ein Businessmodell machen? Oder geht das nicht, weil sich das nicht rentieren könnte? Und und und. Und wir haben in diesem Ideenwettbewerb, wenn der läuft, werden praktisch alle Preise durch eine Jury vergeben. Ausnahme ist ein Preis, das ist ein Publikumspreis, der wird über eine große Abstimmung im Internet vergeben, eine Online-Abstimmung. Und wie man eine social media Marketingkampagne für diese Online-Abstimmung, um möglichst viele Leute für eine Stimmabgabe zu beginnen, das kann man wiederum bei uns im Onlinekurs auf der Zukunftsmacher-Plattform lernen. Und dann findet ab Mitte Februar immer für drei Wochen dieses Online-Voting statt und da kommen sehr viele Leute auf die Plattform, weil natürlich alle 70 teilnehmenden Projekte ihre eigene Kampagne machen. Und das führt dazu, dass also 70.000-120.000 Leute in drei Wochen auf der Plattform sind. Und bei Goldeimer war das dann so, dass … die hatten natürlich noch nicht angefangen, auch nur ihre Toiletten zu bauen. Dann hatten die schon fünf Festivals, die Interesse hatten daran, sich gemeldet hatten bei ihnen und sie buchen wollten für den Sommer.
Und da wussten die sozusagen, da gibt es Interesse, hatten die Kontakte für ihren ersten Piloten. Haben dann in den Werkstätten hier der ehemaligen Kunsthochschule hier in Kiel, Muthesius Kunsthochschule, konnten die Werkstätten nutzen und haben da diese Toiletten gebaut, ihre ersten beiden Prototypen. Sind dann im Sommer auf die Festivals gefahren und haben also gesehen, dass Festivalbesucher durchaus bereit sind, 2-2,50 Euro pro Toilettenbesuch zu bezahlen.
Ja, um eine saubere Toilette zu haben, eine saubere Komposttoilette. Und haben daraus dann im nächsten Schritt ein Geschäftsmodell entwickelt. Haben dann gegründet eine GmbH, wo dann dahinterstehen Kapitalgeber aus dem Bereich Viva con Agua und Festivalbetreiber. Und diese GmbH hat sich jetzt seit 2-3 Jahren weiterentwickelt. Es gibt einige Leute, die jetzt ganzjährig fest angestellt sind. Zwar mit keinen sehr hohen Gehältern, aber trotzdem. Und es gibt ein halbes Dutzend Leute, die saisonmäßig beschäftigt sind. Und sehr interessant. Es gibt ungefähr 150 Leute inzwischen, die auf den Festivals freiwillig Toiletten putzen. Die Festivalbetreiber stellen ein Gratisticket für Leute bereit. Dann verpflichtet man sich für drei Stunden am Tag beim Putzen, Betreuen der Goldeimer Komposttoiletten auf dem Festival mitzuhelfen. Und es gibt einen riesigen Andrang von Leuten, die Lust haben, das zu machen.
Wirklich?
Weil die Szene interessant ist, und weil es außerdem was ist, was die Leute als sinnvoll betrachten. Und ich glaube diese Frage, was sinnvolles tun und lernen zu wollen, ist eine ganz entscheidende für viele junge Leute heute. Goldeimer, vielleicht um die Geschichte zu Ende zu bringen, haben gesehen, na gut das ist ein Saisongeschäft, die sind jetzt im vierten Jahr ungefähr. Eigentlich brauchen wir was, was saisonunabhängiger ist. Haben jetzt also eine eigene Toilettenpapiermarke auf den Markt gebracht letztes Jahr. Die also inzwischen in immer mehr Supermärkten erst im Hamburger Raum, inzwischen in Norddeutschland ist. Und wo natürlich dann ein Anteil der Erlöse wiederum an Goldeimer geht, ein kleiner Anteil davon geht auch wiederum in Sanitärprojekte, die Viva con Agua mit der Welthungerhilfe macht. Ein anderer Teil geht in den Betrieb dieser Toiletten auf den Festivals. Also wir sehen sozusagen, wie das immer weiter wächst. Und dahinter steht ein sehr fites Team, die halt über die Jahre immer mehr dazu gelernt haben.
Und die inzwischen auch für uns sehr wichtig sind, weil sie zum Beispiel zum Summer Camp kommen und Nachwuchsteams mit betreuen.
Das heißt das Klopapier ist jetzt gar nichts besonderes, es ist einfach nur Klopapier, aber durch dieses Branding kanalisiert man eben auch …
Für einen sinnvollen Zweck.
Man organisiert darüber sozusagen die Unterstützung.
Also Goldeimer ist organisiert, hat einen gemeinnützigen Verein, hat die GmbH und aus den Überschüssen aus dem Festival und Toilettenpapiergeschäft gehen wiederum Erträge an Viva con Agua, die damit Sanitär- und Trinkwasserprojekte im Süden, in Ländern in Afrika zum Beispiel finanzieren. Also das ist sozusagen der sozialunternehmerische Ansatz.
Ja ist auch eine super Paarung so von der Komposttoilette zum Frischwasser. Die Brücke muss man auch erst mal schlagen.
Ja. Aber Sie können sehen, wie sich solche Projekte weiterentwickeln können. Wir stellen das nicht als Anforderung an den Anfang des Programms, weil wir sagen allen Leuten, es ist ein Lernprogramm, es ist kein Gründungsprogramm. Also wir wollen, dass ihr lernt, wie ihre eine Idee in die Wirklichkeit bringt und daraus ein Projekt macht. Und wenn dieses Projekt nach diesem ersten Jahr, wenn ihr denkt, es ist für euch zu Ende, dann ist das vollkommen okay. Das hat auch was mit unserer … wir denken tatsächlich so ein Lernprogramm, die Anforderung da reinzustellen, dass jeder gründen sollte, das überfrachtet das Ganze. Finden wir natürlich toll, wenn auch dauerhaftere Dinge dabei entstehen, auch Unternehmen, aber es ist nicht unser primäres Ziel hinter dem Programm.
Aber so oder so kommt da ja eine sehr interdisziplinäre Maßnahme bei heraus. Also wenn man jetzt versucht, über so viele Stufen das Ganze zu begleiten, also sowohl was den sozialen Anspruch betrifft, gut das ist in gewisser Hinsicht mehr so eine Voraussetzung oder vielleicht etwas, was automatisch am Anfang ohnehin schon steht. Aber gerade so dieses Managementwissen, wie führe ich so ein Projekt, wie mache ich mir Gedanken über Finanzierung und so, das sind jetzt nicht unbedingt so klassische Aufgaben der Geografie zum Beispiel. Wie funktioniert das? Heißt das, dass hier auch noch andere Bereiche der Universität da mit reingreifen oder sucht man sich da seine Kooperationspartner außerhalb?
Also das Kernprogramm, wie plane ich, komm ich erst mal von der Idee über die Projektplanung bis zu dem Projektkonzept und wie begleiten wir die Umsetzung dieses Pilotes? Das machen wir bei uns im Team. Das bin ja auch nicht ich alleine. Wir haben inzwischen hier ein Team von einem halben Dutzend Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern, die das machen. Und eine Reihe Studenten, die wir dann noch als studentische Hilfskräfte mit beschäftigen. Und darüber hinaus arbeiten wir, und das ist total wichtig für uns, weil wir natürlich nicht alles abdecken können, das ist natürlich klar, wir sind nicht Experten für alles. Wir haben ein gutes Netzwerk von Personen, die wir einbinden. Zum Beispiel haben wir einen Anwalt, der spezialisierst ist auf sozialunternehmerische Startups. Wi haben jemanden, der spezialisiert ist auf Marketingfragen im Social Enterprise Bereich. Wir haben Leute, die für Teamentwicklung Workshops für uns machen. Und und und. Also diese Leute binden wir da ein, wo wir das brauchen. Wir sind dabei eine Art Beraternetzwerk aufzubauen.
Wir werden diese Art Angebote in eine Art Agenturakademie bündeln, damit sie auch sozusagen über den reinen Hochschulbereich raus verfügbar sind.
Es gibt ja unter anderem auch so einen Ideenwettbewerbe, da haben wir ja eben auch schon drüber gesprochen. Dass man dann eben bei einem erfolgreichen Projekt oder sagen wir mal ein Projekt, was einer Jury gefällt, dann auch eine finanzielle Unterstützung bekommt. Woraus finanziert sich das? Weil das ist ja nicht so üblich, dass dann nochmal Funding gegeben wird für solche Projekte im Rahmen der universitären Tätigkeit.
Also die Finanzierung ist inzwischen tatsächlich aufwendig. Also wir haben einen Finanzierungsbedarf von ungefähr 300.000 Euro im Jahr für das Gesamtprojekt.
Oha.
Was natürlich nicht nur die Uni Kiel ist, sondern wir bieten das ja bundesweit an. Finanziert wird es über diese 300.000 hinaus natürlich durch sozusagen das, was die Uni Kiel, man muss eigentlich sagen, das Land zahlt für meine Stelle. Und in der Arbeitsgruppe für Ressourcen, die wir da mit einbringen. Und die 300.000, die dann verbleiben, werden dann aus einer Mischung unterschiedlichster Quellen müssen die permanent finanziert werden. Wichtig dabei sind Stiftungen, also Stifterverband für die deutsche Wissenschaft, deutsche Stiftung Umwelt, Robert Bosch Stiftung und und und. Energie für Klimaschutz, Gesellschaft für Energie und Klimaschutz in Schleswig-Holstein. Also wir versuchen möglichst viele Finanzierer reinzukriegen, um unsere Finanzierung halt auch nicht von einem einzelnen abhängig zu machen. Jetzt haben wir europäische Regionalfördermittel mit drin, wo die Staatskanzlei sehr behilflich war. Das Wirtschaftsministerium. Das Wissenschaftsministerium hier in Schleswig-Holstein finanziert immer wieder Teile mit. Also das ist ein Finanzierungsmix.
Aus dem wir halt einerseits die Mitarbeiter finanzieren und dann natürlich die Ideenwettbewerbspreisgelder. Das ist im Augenblick so bei 50.000-60.000 Euro pro Jahr. Und das nächste, was wir planen, ist eigentlich, wie es uns gelingen wird eigentlich Unternehmen reinzuziehen als Finanzierer, die wir als ideale Partner sehen. Weil die einerseits inhaltlich Wissen mitbringen, das wir im Hochschulbereich nicht haben, aber das für unsere Projekte sehr interessant wäre, für die Teams sehr interessant wäre. Und gleichzeitig denken wir, dass der Teilnehmerkreis von Menschen, die sich an dem YOOWEEDOO-Programm beteiligt als Nutzer, als Studierende, die Projekte planen und dann auch umsetzen, das ist natürlich eine ganz attraktive Zielgruppe. Also das sind Leute, die sonst auch die Möglichkeit haben, mit Stipendium ins Ausland zu gehen. Die Studienstiftungen sind hinter ihnen her.
Das ist eine sehr attraktive Zielgruppe und deswegen hoffen wir, dass es uns im nächsten Schritt gelingt, ein Unternehmernetzwerk aufzubauen, die in dem Projekt sich beteiligen und auch Finanzierung mit beisteuern. Beratung mit einbringen.
So in zweiter Konsequenz ist das ja im Prinzip auch ein kostenloses Angebot für andere Universitäten. Und das mag ein Abfallprodukt sein, nach dem Motto, naja wir haben es ja eh schon gebaut, warum sollen es nicht auch andere nutzen? Klar kann man so sehen, macht natürlich auch nochmal extra Arbeit.
Ist es aber eigentlich nicht. Weil wir haben das Programm, und diese Überlegungen kommen natürlich aus diesem social Entrepreneurship-Bereich, das habe ich von Ashoka gelernt muss ich echt sagen. Dass wenn man denkt, man hat ein Problem, was sehr viele Leute betrifft und ich würde sagen, dieses Problem, dass Studierende nicht lernen, wie sie aus einer Idee eine Realität machen, das betrifft praktisch alle unsere 2,7 Millionen Studierenden in Deutschland. Es gibt sehr wenige Hochschulen und Studiengänge, wo Studenten so was lernen. Und deswegen war das Projekt von Anfang an immer so geplant von der Strategie her, wie können wir Angebote machen, die mit sehr geringen Kosten skalierbar sind auf einen größeren Teilnehmerkreis, ohne dass uns die Kosten explodieren. Weil wir denken, eigentlich sollten das viel mehr Studierende an viel mehr deutschen Hochschulen machen können so was. Und diese halt Sachen lernen können. Und nicht, dass ich Leute zwangsverarzten möchte damit.
Aber ich denke, jeder, der Interesse hat das zu lernen, jeder Student sollte so was lernen können. Ich habe es selber immer als riesiges Manko empfunden, in den Studiengängen, die ich selber mitgemacht habe als Student, dass genau so was nicht passierte. Und wenn ich die Studiengänge heute angucke, die ich kenne, auch an dieser Hochschule, dann sind die allermeisten weitab davon, dass Studenten so etwas lernen können. Und gleichzeitig sind es aber die Art so, die Studierenden, die so was können, die Problemlöser, die eigentlich alle suchen hinterher. Ob das jetzt in den Ministerien ist, ob das in Unternehmen ist. Alle Leute hätten gerne solche Personen, die diese Fähigkeiten haben, aber das Bildungssystem ist gar nicht drauf vorbereitet, die auszubilden.
Heißt das, dass es gar kein Interesse von anderen Universitäten gibt, da jetzt sozusagen mit einzusteigen?
Doch klar gibt es schon. Aber Sie können sich natürlich vorstellen, an kann nicht so leicht sagen, andere Universitäten, sondern das sind dann meistens Dozenten und Dozentinnen, also Einzelpersonen, die sagen, ich möchte das für meinen Bereich.
Von anderen Universitäten.
Ja so rum funktioniert es wieder.
Weil den Gedanken wollte ich einfach gerade mal ein bisschen weiter spielen. Weil es ja im Prinzip auch sehr neu gedacht ist. Üblicherweise geht man immer davon aus, eine Universität hat so ihre Angebote für ihre Studenten und dann ruht das so in sich. Klar hier und da hat man mal interdisziplinäre Forschung und man tauscht sich ja auch aus und dieses und jenes, aber das ist ja auch nur immer so marginal, aber was die Lehre selber betrifft oder eben auch den konkreten Austausch von Werkzeugen und dann eben damit natürlich auch von Kursinhalten. Im Prinzip kann man ja hier einen Kurs auf einmal an mehreren Universitäten gleichzeitig durchführen, wenn ich jetzt nicht irgendwas gänzlich missverstanden habe.
Nein genauso ist es.
Das ist ja schon eigentlich eine ganz neue Idee eigentlich. Die, wenn ich das jetzt mal so naiv aus einer Perspektive einer Universität betrachte, ja klar, man läuft dann schnell in dieses not invented here Syndrom vielleicht rein, dass das so Ablehnung erfährt, weil das kommt ja nicht von uns. Aber wenn man mal offen ist, dann kann man ja sagen, ja super, da ist ja schon so viel Arbeit gemacht, da können wir doch einfach mal mit einsteigen. Und dann wäre das dann vielleicht auch irgendwie in letzter Konsequenz auch eine Methode dann eben auch Geld zu sparen, indem man das einfach gemeinsam finanziert?
Universitätsübergreifende Lehrtätigkeit.
Ja.
Wissen Sie, das Problem ist ja eigentlich viel gravierender als Sie das darstellen. Das ist ja nicht nur sozusagen unsere Universität und darin gibt es dann ein Programm für unsere Studenten, sondern meistens ist es ja sozusagen unser Fach. Also Studiengänge werden ja von Fächern angeboten. Und es gibt ja schon viele Studiengänge, die sozusagen also einfach nicht mal die Fachgrenzen überschreiten. Wo man vielleicht noch ein stiefmütterliches Nebenfachangebot hat oder dann vielleicht auch mal fünf Leistungspunkte erlaubt, die dann der Student frei wählen kann. Aber selbst innerhalb einer Hochschule ist es ja kein einfaches Problem und ich will da niemanden individuell für haftbar machen. Das ist einfach die Art, wie Hochschulen organisiert sind in Deutschland. Und das macht es schwierig zusammen zu arbeiten. Wir denken aber, dass das total hilfreich wäre und ich denke auch, dass es in Zukunft viel mehr passieren wird. Sicher auch weil das die Entwicklung von Internet und so weiter auch möglich macht, weil das ja sehr viel erleichtert hat.
Man muss natürlich immer gucken, diejenigen, die Lehre organisieren an Hochschulen, also die Dozenten, wir sollen ja alle so eierlegende Wollmilchsäue sein. Wir sollen forschen, wir sollen die Verwaltung der Uni mittragen, selbstverwaltete Hochschulen. Wo letzten Endes die Dozenten die Alltagsadministration mit leisten müssen, weil es keine ausreichend ausgestattete Verwaltungsebene gibt. Und dann neben der Forschung sollen wir dann auch noch super Lehre machen. Die meisten, gerade die engagierten, stehen unter einem riesigen Zeitstress. Das heißt man muss gucken, wie kann man denn die Leute, die einerseits engagiert sind, aber gerade weil sie das sind, halt auch mit der Zeit besonders eng sind, wie kann man
es für die einfach machen, so was für ihre Studenten einzurichten. Und dafür sind die Angebote, die wir in dem Changeleader-Programm jetzt ausgearbeitet haben und die wir jetzt ab Herbst mit den ersten Hochschulen testen, das will ich nur sagen, also seit vier Jahren haben wir die Online-Lernangebote.
Aber dass wir jetzt ein spezielles Programm haben, wo es zum Beispiel neben dem, also das ist ja eigentlich ein Blended Learning Format, der Projektplanungskurs, wo wir einmal online Lerninhalte nutzen, aber durchaus auch Präsenzworkshops haben und wie plant man so ein Blended Learning Programm für die eigene Hochschule.
Also Blended Learning bezeichnet jetzt die Verschmelzung von Online- und Präsenzukursen?
Genau. Was passiert in den Präsenzworkshopanteilen? Wir haben dann genaue Ablaufpläne für diese Präsenzworkshops, die wir auch gerne zur Verfügung stellen dann. Bis hin zu der PowerPoint, die sie brauchen, also einfach den Aufwand so ein Programm zu starten und selber zu testen an der eigenen Hochschule, dass man den so niedrig wie möglich hält.
Tja das klingt doch wie eine tolle Idee. Der Zuspruch ist da für das Projekt. Was wünschen Sie sich so für die nächste Zukunft an Entwicklung? Was wäre denn das tollste, was jetzt sozusagen als nächstes passieren könnte, der Zuspruch ist ja da. Interesse ist da, genug Leute schauen zu, Projekte gelingen. Was könnte man sich jetzt noch wünschen? Außer mehr Finanzierung natürlich?
Die Finanzierungsfrage denke ich mir muss eigentlich systematisch geklärt werden. Ich denke, auf Bundesebene müsste es einen Finanzierungstopf geben beim BMBF oder wo auch immer. Aber im Bereich der Bundesregierung, wo innovative Lehrvorhaben individuelle Finanzierung beantragen können. Weil meistens gibt es, also beim BMBF zum Beispiel gibt es diese Programme wie Hochschulpakt Lehre, die aber nur die Hochschule beantragen kann, aber in diesem Fall sehen wir, dass eigentlich die einzelnen Dozenten eine Möglichkeit bräuchten Gelder zu bekommen, das kommt fast nie aus der Hochschule oder man muss einfach sagen, wenn dann in verschwindend geringem Umfang. Und für so was fehlt in Deutschland ein Finanzierungsformat. Von daher denke ich mir, dass eigentlich für so was ein Format gebraucht wird, in dem das passieren kann. Und ich habe die gute Hoffnung, dass das BMBF möglicherweise in den kommenden Jahren so was auch entwickeln wird.
Aber unabhängig davon, wir denken, dass es für uns der nächste Schritt wäre, wenn wir mit einem Kreis von vielleicht 5-10 Hochschulen enger zusammenarbeiten können. Weil wir denken, es hätte einen riesigen Mehrwert für die Studierenden aller Hochschulen, aber auch für die Dozenten, ein engeres Netzwerk zu haben, wo man Dinge wirklich gemeinsam machen kann. Zum Beispiel die Zukunftsmacher-Plattform. Wir sind jetzt dazu übergegangen, nachdem wir als erstes Lehrkonzept mit dem MOOC gearbeitet haben. Wir haben gesehen, dass so ein MOOC vom Umfang her mal konzipiert wurde mit der Idee, wir ersetzen zwei Semesterwochenstunden Lehrveranstaltung durch einen Onlinekurs einen integrierten. Und wir haben gesehen, dass sowohl für die Studierenden als auch für die Lehrenden das ein eigentlich zu umfangreiches Format ist. Weil da sind 120 Lerneinheiten drin, das kostet einfach relativ viel Zeit, sich damit vertraut zu machen.
Und wir sind jetzt dazu übergegangen kleiner Lernmodule, Online-Lernmodule zu konzipieren. Die sehen so aus, dass man also vom Umfang her immer so denkt, was würde man vermitteln können in einem halbtägigen Workshop zum Thema zum Beispiel Rechtsformen für sozialunternehmerische Startups. Dann beauftragen wir einen Autoren, der auf diesen Bereich spezialisiert ist, jemand, der sich gut damit auskennt, mit uns gemeinsam ein Lernmodul zu konzipieren und das dann auch zu schreiben als Autor. Wir selber bitten dann die Person, auch selber ein Workshop-Konzept dafür auszuarbeiten, damit sozusagen man gleichzeitig also auch jemanden bekommen kann, den man sich anheuern kann. Wir zum Beispiel im Summer Camp, aber auch andere Hochschulen extern, wo man so was durchführen lässt, wenn man selber diese Sachkompetenz nicht hat. Wir können nicht alle alles selber wissen. Muss eigentlich eher als Produzent einer Lehrveranstaltung arbeiten, als als ich kann alles selber.
Und gleichzeitig gibt es dann dazu relativ vom Umfang her begrenzte, aber sehr spezifische Lernmodule, die ich viel leichter auch als Dozent in Lernkonzepte einbinden kann. Und wir sind dazu übergegangen, das jetzt zu machen, das wird auch wiederum von unterschiedlichen Stiftungen gefördert. Die ersten Lernmodule sind jetzt schon im Aufbau. Kann man auch schon finden auf der Zukunftsmacher-Plattform. Wie Rechtsformen für sozialunternehmerische Startups oder auch wie Gemeinnützigkeit. Sozusagen was hat das für steuerliche Folgen. Also an was muss ich denken, wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Verein gründe. Ich könnte ja auch eine gemeinnützige UG gründen, eine Unternehmensgesellschaft. Oder eine gemeinnützige GmbH. Wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Team aufbaue ein kleines, das dann vielleicht dann auch in eine Gründung geht, sozusagen an was muss ich bei Teamentwicklung denken und und und. Und wir würden uns wünschen, dass auch andere Dozenten die Möglichkeiten nutzen, mit uns gemeinsam Lernmodule für diese Lernplattform zu entwickeln.
Weil das würde natürlich den Nutzen für alle potenzieren. Jeder kann das nutzen, das Open Educational Ressource ist online frei verfügbar. Kostet nichts. Je mehr Leute da sinnvolle Inhalte bereitstellen und die dann gemeinsam nutzen, umso spannender wird das Ganze. Und für die Studenten denke ich mir über diesen Aufbau einer realen und auch virtuellen Community, wo Menschen sich auch untereinander beraten können. Das ist ein Bereich, den wir weiter ausbauen wollen, sowohl online als auch offline. Könnte ich gleich ein paar Worte zu sagen. Das sind so Entwicklungen, die wir in den kommenden Jahren vorantreiben werden. Dazu kommt, dass wir zunehmend Anfragen haben auch aus dem ausländischen Bereich. Also auch zum Beispiel haben wir jetzt eine Kooperation, wo wir einen Antrag stellen gemeinsam, um so was mit Universitäten in Kambodscha und auch in Myanmar solche Lernprogramme aufzubauen mit lokalen Partnern.
Mit einer anderen Partnerhochschule in Deutschland. Also es gibt viele Bereiche, die uns interessieren und wo wir gucken, kann man mehr Menschen den Zugang zu dieser Art Lernen ermöglichen? Weil eigentlich denken wir, was sich an Hochschulen ändern muss ist die Art, wie gelernt wird. Ich will nicht sagen was, aber wie gelernt wird.
Ja.
Man sollte lernen, wie man selber ein Problem lösen kann. Das kann ein gesellschaftliches sein, das kann auch ein Forschungsproblem sein. Aber ich glaube, das Gehirn ist entstanden und wir sind entstanden, um in unserem Leben permanent Probleme zu lösen und das ist das, was alle Leute fasziniert, wenn sie sehen, dass sie das können.
Das heißt das Problemlösen muss mehr in den Vordergrund treten in der universitären Ausbildung?
Absolut. Also ich bin überzeugt davon. Ich selber habe ja noch gelernt in einer Zeit, als man auch bei einer Doktorarbeit 90% der Zeit eigentlich damit verbracht hat Literatur hinterher zu jagen. Also sozusagen Fernleihe, Kopieren, das war der Wahnsinn. Also wir haben inzwischen alle sozialisiert, die heutige Professorengeneration so um die 50 aufwärts sind aus dieser Zeit. Während sich eigentlich sozusagen der Fokus, wie komme ich überhaupt an Wissen dran, sich ja komplett verändert hat, durch Internet, Onlinedatenbanken und und und. Aber die Art, wie unterrichtet wird, hat sich nicht verändert in vielen Bereichen. Nach wie vor gibt es viel zu viele Vorlesungen. Da muss man sich doch fragen, was ist der Mehrwert dieser spezifischen Vorlesung jetzt gegenüber zum Beispiel einem Lehrbuch oder einem Onlinekurs, die es zu zigtausenden gibt inzwischen. Manche Vorlesungen haben so einen Mehrwert, viele haben das nicht. Dann gibt es Seminare.
Wo letzten Endes in vielen Seminaren werden Studenten einfach dazu benutzt, nur Inhalte wiederzugeben. Und nicht in allen, aber in vielen. Und ich denke es gibt ganz andere Arten, wie man lernen kann, die ich fassen würde unter dem Bereich Problem Solving Based Learning. Wie kann man es lernen, die Studierenden eigentlich selber Probleme lösen zu lassen. Weil wenn sie ein reales Problem haben, dann wissen sie auch, warum sie bestimmten Stoff brauchen.
Erinnert mich immer wieder an ein schönes Gespräch, was wir hier hatten in Forschergeist 22 mit Jürgen Handke, der Ihnen vielleicht auch was sagt, da ging es um digitale Hochschullehre und die Flipped Classroom-Konzepte. In dem Fall in einem Anglistik-Studium, aber halt mit ähnlichen Erkenntnissen. Dass man eben sozusagen die modernen Entwicklungen einfach an der Stelle zum Einsatz bringen muss, wo sie einfach sinnvoll sind, weil sie quasi eine sinnlose Repetition verhindern. Und dann eben die Präsenzkurse quasi auch auf eine ganz andere Basis stellen, weil sie eben nicht mehr für die Vermittlung der Primärinformationen genutzt werden, sondern eben für die Vertiefung und auch in gewisser Hinsicht auch für so ein zusätzliches Community-Building.
Also wenn ich das etwas ketzerisch ausdrücke, dann denke ich, wir müssen uns doch als Hochschule fragen, was ist eigentlich unsere Rolle in der Gesellschaft und was ist auch unsere Existenzberechtigung? Denn zum Beispiel hier so eine Universität Kiel wir verbrauchen an Landesmitteln jedes Jahr 160 Millionen, haben weitere 100-120 Millionen Drittmittel, und warum sollte die Gesellschaft uns dieses Geld geben? Und wenn ich mir ansehe, wie Hochschulen entstanden sind, Hochschulen waren natürlich einmal sozusagen der Wissensspeicher, für die Gesellschaft, ein wichtiger Wissensspeicher. Waren auch ein Ort, wo Wissen weitergegeben wurde und natürlich auch, wo neues Wissen geschaffen wird. Was natürlich so diese Art Wissensspeicher manifestiert sich ja rein baulich in diesen großen Universitätsbibliotheken. Und wir hatten natürlich ganz wichtig ein Monopol auf die Vergabe von Abschlüssen. Also Hochschulabschlüssen, die wiederum mit dafür entscheidend waren, wer hatte denn eigentlich welche Chancen auf Wohlstand und Mitwirkungsrechte in der Gesellschaft.
Ich habe selber in einer Zeit studiert, da haben 10% eines Jahrgangs in Deutschland, eines Geburtenjahrgangs, studiert, inzwischen sind wir bei knapp 60%. Und wenn ich das rein marktwirtschaftliche betrachte, dann würde ich sagen, hier findet eine Inflation von Hochschulabschlüssen statt, das heißt inzwischen ist es doch fast normal, dass jeder, der sich auf irgendeine Stelle bewirbt, so einen Hochschulabschluss hat. Das stellt ja die Frage, welchen Wert hat das denn noch? Und ich möchte nicht sagen, dass Hochschulabschlüsse nichts wert sind. Man kann das betrachten, dass Hochschulabsolventen trotzdem im Leben besser verdienen, mehr Gehalt kriegen über die Lebenszeit als Leute ohne Hochschulabschluss. Aber ich kann es mir auch andersrum angucken. Zum Beispiel Google seit 2013 gucken die bei ihren Bewerberscreenings. Also sie haben über eine Million Bewerbungen im Jahr und sie gucken überhaupt nicht mehr drauf, wer hat denn welchen Hochschulabschluss? Weil die sagen, der Hochschulabschluss hat keinen Vorhersagewert aus ihren Untersuchungen über die Qualität der Arbeit, die jemand hinterher macht.
Und sie gucken nicht mal mehr, ob jemand von Stanford ist. Und dann frage ich mich natürlich so, welchen Wert hat denn der Hochschulabschluss, wenn Stanford keinen Wert mehr hat für solche Arbeitgeber. Wie ist denn der Wert eines Hochschulabschlusses der Universität Kiel oder jeder anderen deutschen Hochschule. Ich denke das muss man sich als Hochschule perspektivisch fragen. Und ich denke, wir verlieren das Monopol auf die Vergabe von Abschlüssen, weil diese Abschlüsse, dadurch dass immer mehr Menschen sie haben, gesellschaftlich diese Bedeutung nicht mehr haben. Und da stehen wir eigentlich am Anfang eines Prozesses, wenn also Firmen wie Google, die vielleicht Vorreiter sind, sagen, nein wir wählen nach anderen Kriterien aus. Dann werden das in 10 Jahren viel mehr machen. Und wenn ich gleichzeitig sozusagen also mein zweites Monopol verliere, nämlich Zugang zu spezialisiertem Wissen, weil übers Internet heutzutage sehr viel Wissen verfügbar ist und ich dafür nicht notwendigerweise für jede Art von Wissen an eine Hochschule gehen muss …
… dann sind so zwei der zentralen Daseinsberechtigungen für mich als Universität gefährdet durch die Entwicklungen, die einfach passieren, technologische, gesellschaftliche Veränderungen. Und wenn ich dann überlege, was ist eigentlich die Rolle von Hochschule in 20 Jahren, denke ich, es ist Community, es ist Community von Forschern, es ist auch Community von Studierenden, die davon leben, dass sie die Leute real zusammenbringen und diese Leute was machen lassen, was in deren Augen sinnstiftend ist. Und einen Mehrwert hat gegenüber dem, was sie sowieso im Internet oder wo auch immer kriegen können. Und ich denke, gemeinsam an einem Problem arbeiten zu können, was man gemeinsam löst, ist was extrem sinnstiftendes, besonders wenn es Probleme sind, die für die Gesellschaft relevant sind. Sinn können Sie nicht alleine herstellen. Sinn entsteht dadurch, dass jemand anderes das für wichtig betrachtet, was Sie machen.
Und ich glaube, Hochschulen müssen, wenn ich mir das ansehe, was bedeutet das eigentlich für die Art, wie an Hochschulen gelernt wird, glaube ich, dass der Kern von dem, was in 10-20 Jahren an Hochschulen passieren sollte, und vielleicht auch zunehmend wird, vielleicht gar nicht mehr die Vermittlung von Stoff ist primär. Also vielleicht sehr spezialisierter Stoff. Aber der ganze allgemeine Stoff, wie die Einführung in die Betriebswirtschaft, Mikroökonomie, Makroökonomie, Einführung in die Statistik, das gibt es ja heutzutage schon alles im Netz. Dafür brauche ich nicht in eine Vorlesung gehen. Und das gilt für sehr viele disziplinäre Fachbereiche, gerade im Einstiegsbereich. Und es aber einen großen Mehrwert hat, das heißt nicht, dass diese Menschen, die das unterrichtet haben, alle überflüssig sind, ich sage ganz im Gegenteil. Aber die Zeit könnte man besser nutzen, wenn man betreut, wie Studenten relevante Probleme selber zu lösen lernen. Vor dem Hintergrund dieser Fachkontexte. Und die meisten Probleme ordnen sich nicht einem universitär disziplinären Fachkontext unter, sondern die meisten Disziplinen wird man interdisziplinär betrachten müssen.
Das heißt ich glaube innerhalb der Hochschulen wird es eine Verschiebung brauchen, eigentlich wie gelernt wird. Und es wird viel mehr brauchen, dass diese disziplinären Grenzen aufgelöst werden.
Ja und auch um das Beispiel mit Google oder überhaupt großen modernen nach Mitarbeitern suchenden Unternehmen aufzugreifen. Auch da spielt soziales Engagement in zunehmendem Maße eine große Rolle, sowohl für die Gesellschaft als auch in das Team selber, Teambuildung, solche Qualitäten auch so grundsätzliches Verstehen von Managementprozesse auch wirklich voran zu bringen. Probleme zu lösen. Ich glaube das sind die Dinge, nach denen geschaut wird. Und halt nicht der Abschluss. Herr Corves, ich glaube jetzt haben wir es ganz gut umrissen. Das waren schon einige in jeder Hinsicht Ausblicke in die Zukunft schon dabei. Haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen?
Vergessen haben wir sicher nichts. Außer dass ich vielleicht noch anfügen würde, wenn das jemand hört, der Interesse hat mit uns zu arbeiten, ich mich freue, wenn er auf uns zukommt oder sie.
Ja ich sage vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank Ihnen für die Möglichkeit, mit Ihnen hier zu sprechen.
Ja und vielen Dank für wie immer an alle, die hier zuhören und gerne zuhören bei Forschergeist. Ich sage, tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal und bis bald.